un peu de branches maison bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
françois alors concernant le boycott des
produits français ce qu'il y a déjà eu
des précédents
oui ça s'est déjà produit et peut-être
on peut en citer deux exemples parce
qu'ils éclairent la situation actuelle
le premier c'est le boycott des produits
français aux états unis d'amérique en
2003 lorsque la france avait refusé de
participer à la deuxième guerre d'irak
et qu'elle avait dans un débat au
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
pris position très clairement en disant
qu'il n'y avait pas de raison de faire
une nouvelle expédition en irak alors on
avait vu les américains déverser des
bouteilles de champagne dans les
caniveaux à à new york est en effet le
boycott a porté pendant quelques
semaines sur les produits alimentaires
les produits cosmétiques et les produits
de luxe mais ça n'a pas duré très
longtemps
le deuxième exemple eh bien c'est en
turquie
déjà en 2012
à l'époque monsieur le guen était
premier ministre et il voulait empêcher
le sénat français de voter la loi qui
faisait du déni de déni du génocide
arménien à un crime ou sens du code
pénal français bien entendu ça n'a pas
empêché le parlement français d'adopter
cette loi et le génocide arménien le
déni du génocide arménien est devenu un
crime au sens du droit pénal et est bien
le boycott n'a pas eu beaucoup de succès
d'autant plus qu'à l'époque un grand
nombre de turcs se sont aperçus que des
produits français bien les brûlis
français étaient fabriquées en turquie
il ya une usine renault
il y à des produits laitiers qui sont
également fabriquées en turquie et par
conséquent cela risquait produits de
produire du chômage plus qu'autre chose
alors aujourd'hui il ya donc eu ce
soutien des émirats arabes unis à
emmanuel macron à ce que cela est
surprenant
en tout cas moi j'ai envie de dire que
c'est très important que ces courageux
et que ça n'est pas très surprenant
alors c'est important parce que les
émirats arabes unis sont un pays qui
appartient
au conseil de coopération du golfe qu'il
a de très bons rapports avec l'arabie
saoudite avec l'egypte est un pays
influent et que les capitales d'abou
dhabi de dubaï joue un rôle très
important dans au proche orient
par conséquent c'est une c'est une bonne
nouvelle je crois d'autant plus que le
ministre des affaires étrangères dans
son interview à die welt de ce matin dit
il faut écouter monsieur macron il faut
lire monsieur macron et monsieur mâcon
dit il n'est pas question d'un dijonnais
dans un ghetto les musulmans qui il faut
au contraire les intégrer à la
communauté française et qu' il n'a rien
contre la religion musulmane
il veut simplement se battre contre les
extrémistes et contre les terroristes
voilà je pense que d'autres pays
reprendront cet argument c'est courageux
parce que au proche-orient peu de
dirigeants ont tenu ce langage
ouvertement même si beaucoup le pensent
en au fond d'eux mêmes
et puis je pense que cela n'est pas très
surprenant parce que la france a de très
bons rapports très diversifié avec les
émirats arabes unis il ya une
coopération militaire il ya des bases
militaires
il ya une coopération en matière
d'énergie en matière de transport et en
matière culturelle puisque après tout
est bien un louvre abou dhabi alors en
tout cas les manifestations au
bangladesh par exemple se poursuivre
l'entretien du président français sur al
jazeera cela n'a pas suffi à apaiser les
esprits
non alors vous avez raison il ya de
grands pays musulmans en asie vous avez
montré tout à l'heure la situation en
indonésie 190 millions d'avis 290
millions d'habitants on aurait pu parler
du pakistan 190 millions d'habitants et
parler du bangladesh 80 90 millions
d'habitants et dans ces pays les
mouvements islamistes ont appelé à un
boycott et les gouvernements laissent
faire
le président pakistanais le premier
ministre pakistanais pardon à lui-même
encouragé
au boycott des produits français parce
que ça les arrange sur un plan de
politique intérieure et sur le plan des
équilibres intérieurs donc probablement
ce mouvement va durer pendant quelques
quelques quelques semaines mais je pense
que le contre-feu allumé par l'interview
du président macron à la chaîne al
jazeera le relais par le miz affaires
étrangères des émirats arabes unis va
faire son effet dans les autres pays
merci beaucoup claude blanche maison
pour votre analyse je rappelle que vous
êtes expert en relations internationales